le projet de loi que je défends c'est de
mettre en place un test d'aptitude à la
conduite pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors mais avec une
fréquence plus régulière à partir d'un
certain âge il y a un contrôle technique
de la voiture il faut faire un contrôle
technique du conducteur à chaque fois
qu'il y a un accident ou l'inaptitude
d'un conducteur et est en jeu j'ai une
colère qui revient de manière très aiguë
et c'est difficile à gérer mais en même
temps ça me redonne encore toujours une
force une énergie pour continuer ce
combat pour continuer de convaincre le
gouvernement la population de faire
quelque chose ces missions qui est utile
pour tout le monde
c'est valable dans d'autres domaines à
l'aviation on fait on peut contrôler
tous les 5 ans je crois pour les poids
lourds c'est la législation pour les
pour la voiture a priori pas moi je
trouve qu'elle est entièrement raison
elle a très très bien parlé mais
maintenant quel âge elle définit c'est
ça elle a parlé d'âge ou de seniors mais
c'est quel âge que les seniors
ont dit c'est 45 c'est 55 c'est 65
regardez la réforme des retraites c'est
là je suis seniors
ici d'accord
65 rendez-vous au permis de conduire
non ce ce pourquoi je suis d'accord
effectivement c'est une visite médicale
c'est la vue c'est les réflexes etc
c'est nécessaire maintenant il y a pas
que des personnes de certaines âges qui
qui tuent des gens malheureusement
tous les 10 ans quel que soit l'âge
parce qu'on peut très bien
moi efficace
je suppose qu'un pilote de Formule 1 que
Alain prose je pense qu'il est encore en
mesure de conduire sur sa voiture elle
est assez bien
des contrôles font des contrôles tous
les 10 ans effectivement je suis quand
on perd son permis on a comme moi j'ai
perdu mon permis par exemple ah vous
voyez j'ai perdu les gars
j'ai perdu pour je l'ai perdu et en fait
quand j'ai repassé j'ai plus de points
et quand je l'ai repassé j'ai passé des
tests d'aptitudes de réflexe avec des
lumières je vous le dis c'est très
compliqué donc je suis pas certain que
des personnes un peu bien sûr quand on
d'enlever votre permis je j'ai un trou
de mémoire je me rappelle
une course avec un TGV c'est pas 50 ans
en tout cas non non oui Gilles moi je
suis contre toi même si
le drame que Madame dérouler drague
raconte il est il est réel donc voilà
c'est difficile épouvantable mais
néanmoins néanmoins je trouve que c'est
toujours très compliqué de discriminer
les seniors de discriminer par rapport à
l'âge parce que ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que dans nos campagnes les
gens qui prennent leur voiture pour
aller acheter du pain ils pourront plus
le faire donc vous allez contribuer à
l'isolement des céréales
parce que en fait leur faire repasser
des contrôles ça va influer sur leur
mental ça va aller faire l'avenir
excusez-moi
un contrôle adapté parce que
effectivement si c'est des contrôles
comme pour comme pour les jeunes avec
des lumières qui dégueulent de partout
c'est sûr qu'ils vont être handicapés
ils ont pas ça
qui roulent sans permis en ce moment
tous ceux qui roulent avec vous avez
raison
tu peux dire aussi
il prend le métro en plus il conduit pas
moi je peux vous dire je suis en scooter
alors j'ai rien contre les personnes
âgées au contraire mais ça m'est arrivé
une fois à l'entrée de de l'autoroute où
il faut justement accélérer et ben il y
avait un petit papi qui est roulait très
doucement alors moi j'ai failli me faire
écouter
une zone d'accélération quand on prend
l'autoroute
je failli passer à cause d'un petit quoi
on va profiter de notre public
à Madame alors madame qui est très
active
est-ce que vous êtes vous seriez pour
qu'on vous fasse un petit test pour le
permis de conduire je déteste conduire
j'ai mon permis mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord et voilà tout à fait logique
madame qui a 87 ans
[Musique]
est-ce que quelqu'un est contre une
personne
pour parce que contrairement à ce que
dit Gilles moi ma mère elle a pas
conduit pendant un certain temps parce
qu'elle a eu un petit souci de santé et
elle m'a dit j'aimerais bien avant de
m'y remettre repasser peut-être un petit
test pour voir si je suis pas là encore
hâte à conduire parce que ça la rassure
au contraire elle est plus en confiance
n'importe quoi
je tombe des nues quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]